I didn't ask to be super and I'm no hero
but your worst enemy is after your best
girl it's time to be a superhero let's
get out there and make a difference
wait did I leave the stove on
Deadpool look like an avocado had sex
with an older avocado thank you
hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's a
new Deadpool footage I thought I'd cook
some Sunday tacos so here we go my
favorite thing about Deadpool right now
isn't even the movie that's coming which
is gonna be awesome by the way but the
fact that Deadpool is now the new
Wolverine of the x-men Fox universe in
that Ryan Reynolds is kind of like a
Hugh Jackman type figure Hugh Jackman is
slowly leaving The Wolverine character
behind
he still has a Wolverine solo film to do
that's not gonna come for a little while
so we still have that but Hugh Jackman
is this big a-list actor that Fox kind
of built the x-men films around for a
long time then when Jennifer Lawrence
blew up they started to make the movies
revolve around her a little bit more
like the new x-men apocalypse film look
at how much Mystique's character is in
that trailer
she's like the leader of the Opposition
in that movie and it's all because
Jennifer Lawrence is a great actress but
she's also one of the biggest stars on
the planet and that's usually what
studios look for when they look for
characters to build films around and
even though the x-men franchise is a big
ensemble cast it's a huge cast of
characters you typically have to have
like one or two big characters to build
the movie around Hugh Jackman was one of
the few people to survive the big x-men
reboot now I know they did Days of
Future past and they brought a bunch of
the classic x-men actors back but
Wolverine is still Hugh Jackman no
matter what time period you're in that
is because he is a huge bankable star
and I feel like Ryan Reynolds is the
next version of that for them Deadpool
as a character has had team ups with all
kinds of comfortable characters Spidey
pool is just the latest big one we have
to talk about that in a second - but
what I'm expecting is is that after
x-men apocalypse you'll start seeing
Deadpool pop up in all these different
films like you would see Wolverine cameo
in a bunch of different films I feel
like okay we'll put Wolverine in it
that'll get people really excited like
holy crap Wolverine is kicking ass in
this other person's movie x-force is a
really good example of a risk
inside this x-men universe for Fox it's
a title that most people who don't read
comics won't be familiar with Wolverine
was part of x-force in the comics and
normally I think they would try to throw
Hugh Jackman into it just to support the
movie but because Hugh Jackman's deal is
expiring and it'd just be too expensive
to put him in the movie
I feel like Deadpool would be good proxy
for that Deadpool also a huge part of
x-force and that's just one example you
don't need him quite as much in a big
x-men film but Jennifer Lawrence is
leaving the franchise - so Fox is
looking for their next Hugh Jackman
Wolverine in actor
amazing that everybody loves with a
character that's really interesting to
write and it sounds like that's what
Deadpool might end up being now the
Deadpool movie hasn't come out I haven't
seen it yet so I can't say that it's the
most amazing thing to ever hit cinema
but I totally think that Ryan Reynolds
would be down to be their next Hugh
Jackman it means a ton more money for
him and when he guest stars in other
films like he does the Hugh Jackman type
cameo the Wolverine type cameo he only
has to be on set for a couple days so
it's a relatively easy proposition and
usually when really big actors do stuff
like this when they they pop up in a
bunch of different films usually the
benefits go beyond money like they Forge
a big relationship with the studio so
they do their passion project so it's
like hey I want to do these for small
films but I'll do these big x-men films
for you too so don't be surprised if you
see Ryan Reynolds start popping up as
Deadpool in a bunch of different films
it's super awesome but then between
those big films you see Bryan Reynolds
doing a bunch of smaller passion
projects that he has much more control
over distributed by Fox that's really
what you see big actors like Robert
Downey jr. do where it's like they do
these big films you know they're Iron
Man for the rest of their life but they
use that influence and power or money to
make small films that really interest
them so let me know in the comments do
you think that Fox eventually is going
to start using Deadpool the same way it
uses wolverine and all of its x-men
universe films because they are working
on x-force
they're working on New Mutants so
there's just like a bunch of titles the
Deadpool was a big part of in the comics
it just makes sense that if Ryan
Reynolds is gonna be one of the biggest
stars in the planet you're gonna put him
in all those films the real hard part
though is when you use characters like
Deadpool and Wolverine in movies in a
small way without it either feeling
stupid or them completely taking over
the plot imagine if you tried to do
x-men first class but apocalypse showed
up suddenly the movie wouldn't be about
them assembling the team for the first
time Xavier school it'd be all about
apocalypse like you would completely
forget about what everyone else was
doing so upside downside I think it'd be
a good idea to try and use Deadpool at
least in a minor way in some of these
other films Ryan Reynolds totally fits
the mold huge relatively bankable star
internationally super popular with a
character that people really love either
way Jennifer Lawrence and Hugh Jackman
have both announced they're done with
x-men films now Hugh Jackman still has
Wolverine but Jennifer Lawrence has done
after Apocalypse and just a circle back
around a spider-man I know everybody
wondering about spider-man because they
just rebooted the character with Tom
Holland we haven't really seen him yet
at any of the trailers we don't know how
they're gonna use him going forward
beyond the Sony film they're gonna be
their own story and then the Marvel
films that he appears in although
technically it's all connected because
spider-man is now part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
it sounds more complicated than it
actually is but I feel like spider-man
could be in Marvel's films the same
thing that Deadpool could be in the
x-men films just the character that pops
up everywhere and if you haven't been
reading it you should totally check out
Spidey pool it started a couple years
ago now they've rebooted it because of
Secret Wars but there is a spider-man
and Deadpool comic where they team up
most of the fun because they are wise
crackers is that they have this Odd
Couple relationship where spider-man is
like great power great responsibility
but Deadpool is great power zero
responsibility and there's actually a
really awesome really deep cut if you
haven't read it a story where Deadpool
goes back to an amazing spider-man story
like way way back in the Golden Age of
spider-man's comics modern writers wrote
him into a classic spider-man tale if
you ever watch Mystery Science Theater
3000 it's kind of like Deadpool's
version of that he goes back and kind of
lives this spider-man story through
Peter Parker's eyes so like you see
these yellow bubbles here this is
Deadpool talking as Peter Parker not
exactly a spider-man Deadpool team-up
but Spidey pool before Spidey pool
became a thing do you just feel like if
Marvel and Fox would ever come to an
arrangement where they share a character
Deadpool would be that character the
tone of Deadpool is much closer to the
way they write those Avengers movies
anyway so I feel like he'd be perfect in
their franchise if you haven't seen any
of the videos I've posted about Marvel
and DC stuff next week next week is
technically DC week but there's still a
bunch of Marvel stuff happening and
still some Deadpool stuff that'll
probably drop too so just be sure to
subscribe to get everything and I'll put
links in the description that'll explain
everything if you don't know what's
going on there's a bunch of trailers
coming new Suicide Squad or the first
Wonder Woman trailer I should say flash
is coming back bunch of DC shows
starting all kinds of awesome stuff
hopefully you guys enjoy those breakfast
tacos while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
reverse flash Returns trailer video and
you can click here for all my Deadpool
videos thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you